the city of gaziantep lies about 65
kilometers from the syrian border
since the war broke out in syria
hundreds of thousands of refugees have
found sanctuary here
among them are many syrian journalists
one of them is a young reporter who
we'll call ahmad
he's been researching the brutal
atrocities committed by the so-called
islamic state
he no longer feels safe in turkey and
lives in hiding
after a long wait for an interview we
meet him in an empty playground on the
edge of town
my family lived for a while in an i.s
controlled area
before they were able to flee they were
threatened repeatedly because of an
article i wrote then is started
threatening me directly
writing that they would find me and kill
me
i can work from home and i don't leave
my apartment
unless it's absolutely necessary and i
change a dress
on a regular basis
his fears are not unfounded in mid-may
his colleague muhammad shahar
shagat was shot point blank on this
street corner in broad daylight
al shergat had also published material
on the crimes committed by is
in syria
it happened over there on the pavement
the gunman fled on foot
we were just sitting here in front of
the shop we get murders now bomb attacks
missiles coming over from syria we've
gotten used to it
was the fourth syrian journalist to be
murdered in turkish cities near the
border
in mid-june this man survived an attack
but was severely wounded
each time islamic state claimed
responsibility
but not once has a suspect been arrested
how is it possible that this brutal
terrorist organization can operate with
impunity in turkey
we drive to the syrian border region
accompanied by adi demirhan
a turkish human rights activist
he's long been investigating the
activities of is and other radical
islamic groups in the border region
he says border installations on the
turkish side have been fortified
but they don't hinder the jihadists
they climb over walls crawl through
tunnels or come across green areas that
are not guarded
according to official statistics between
500 and 1500 people cross the border
illegally every day
turkish border town of reihani is
considered a stronghold of is
and other radical islamic groups from
syria
a monument pays tribute to 53 people
killed in an is bomb attack
syrians are now in the majority in the
town
no one is willing to talk to us about
i.s
we know that there are groups here which
help militant jihadists from syria with
smuggling
and getting in and out of the country
reihanli
is the jihadist logical center this
is the hub where everything comes
together from both sides of the border
turkish human rights activists also
discovered this
syrian children working in a garment
factory in turkey making uniforms for
the war back home
is fighters are reported to be among the
customers
but asking questions about is here in
the border area is clearly unwelcome
shortly after we started filming we were
stopped by plainclothes police officers
in order to
leave the town
but demirjhan has more to show us
he takes us to a deportation center for
foreigners some 30 kilometers from
reynolds
he says many foreign is fighters are
held here
although rarely for longer than a few
weeks
although they're suspected is terrorists
they just get deported after a short
while to a third country
without being charged everything that
happens in this deportation center is
secret
the turkish secret service is in charge
here we think it's basically a transit
center for jihadists
we tried to talk to the governor of
gaziantep about the center
and about the killing of syrian
journalists in turkey
but our requests for an interview got no
response
even turkey's chief state prosecutor
views gaziantep as the headquarters of
is in turkey
since the murder of his friend naji jaf
who was lured into an ambush despite
taking precautions
ahmad no longer trusts the turkish state
suspect that parts of the security
apparatus in turkey
are working together with is but we
can't prove it
corruption is very widespread in turkey
civil service
and because of the close proximity to
syria it's very
tempting for some to try to make money
from the war
could turkish officials have been
accessories to murder and return for
bribes
it's a serious accusation the murderers
of ahmed's colleagues might still be in
gaziantep
he's keen to get back into hiding before
darkness falls